was isst du gern was isst du gern ich
esse gern teigwaren
ich esse gern fisch ich esse gern gemüse
ich esse gern teigwaren
was isst du oft
ich esse oft reiße ich esse oft
kartoffeln
ich esse oft fleisch
ich esse oft reiße ich esse oft
kartoffeln
ich esse oft fleisch was isst du nie ich
esse nie fleisch
ich bin vegetarier ich essen ii
schweinefleisch
ich bin moslem
ich esse nie knoblauch
schmerzen ich esse nie fleisch
[Musik]
ich bin vegetarier ich essen ii
schweinefleisch
ich bin moslem
ich esse nie knoblauch
komme ich bauchschmerzen was isst du zum
frühstück ich frühstücke meistens brot
mit butter und konfitüre oder honig
und dazu trinke ich einen kaffee
ich frühstücke meistens brot mit butter
und konfitüre oder honig
und dazu trinke ich einen kaffee
ich esse gern deftig eier mit speck
würstchen pilzen und bohnen
dazu trinke ich einen tee und einen
orangensaft
ein englisches frühstück
ich esse gern deftig eier mit speck
würstchen pilzen und bohnen
dazu trinke ich einen tee und einen
orangensaft
ein englisches frühstück
meistens essig frühstücksflocken mit
einem joghurt und eine frucht
meistens es sich einen apfel einem 4
sich oder erdbeeren
dazu trinke ich gerne ein glas milch
oder einen smoothie
meistens essig frühstücksflocken mit
einem joghurt und eine frucht
meistens es sich einen apfel einem 4
sich oder erdbeeren
dazu trinke ich gern ein glas milch oder
einen smoothie
ich gehe in den supermarkt einkaufen
kann ich etwas mitbringen
kauft bitte brot milch und butter
ja bring bitte ein stück kuchen und eine
flasche cola mit kauf bitte brot milch
und butter
ja bring bitte ein stück kuchen und eine
flasche cola mit
guten tag frau riss geht sie herr krüger
ach sie haben schwere taschen kann ich
ihnen helfen
ja gern das ist
freundlich
ja gern das ist sehr freundlich
[Musik]
können sie bitte diese tasche tragen
natürlich kein problem
diese tasche ist aber schwer
ja ich habe sehr viel eingekauft viel
gemüse viel obst und einen fisch
aha deshalb ist die tasche so schwer
ich muss später auch einkaufen
aber heute besuch meine kollegen von der
arbeit kommen zu mir
wir machen pizza
pizza fein
so vielen dank für ihre hilfe
gern geschehen
auf wiedersehen und viel spaß heute
abend
danke auf wiedersehen
matthias komm wir essen gleich
je
es gibt es
zuerst einen salat
[Musik]
dann gibt es spaghetti mit tomatensoße
fleisch
lecker
hmm
und wer den salat gegessen hat bekommt
zum dessert eine kugel eis
und wer den salat
essen hat bekommt zum dessert eine kugel
eis
bitte zuerst die hände und hilf mir
danach den tisch zu decken
was stier bitte zuerst die hände und
hilf mir danach den tisch zu decken
ich habe die handicap
ich habe die hände
m
[Musik]
kannst jetzt bitte den tisch decken
was braucht
wir
ja
was brauchen wir
für jede person einen teller für die
spaghetti und eine kleine schüssel für
den salat
für jede person einen teller für die
spaghetti und eine kleine schüssel für
den salat
[Musik]
einen großen löffel eine gabel ein
messer und einen kleinen löffel für den
dessert
einen großen löffel eine gabel ein
messer und einen kleinen löffel für den
dessert
und natürlich ein glas für den ice t
achtung matthias
die gabel und der löwe muss du links
neben den teller legen
das messe kommt immer rechts
und der kleine löffel für den dessert
musst du über oder hinter den teller
legen
die gabel und der löwe muss du links
neben den teller legen
das messer kommt immer rechts
und der kleine löwe für den dessert
musst du über oder hinter den teller
legen
abonniere die halo deutsch schule auch
auf instagram oder facebook
abonniere die halo deutsche schule auch
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal